the wild made a couple of moves yesterday
couple of Trades moving in is Baldi sa by
Dain this is really a good move he feels
he's got plenty plenty of hockey left to
give meris moves it past Middleton kept in
nice play by gustavson L forier centers tro
scores oh Vince tro staying hot snapped one from
high in the slot rers lead one- nothing this is
Eric gson watch the reach right there reaches
around the Minnesota player to keep it alive and
then a couple of passes and it ends up in the
net so Gerson was aggressive and then tro Che
who's been hot and that shot Jones with a little
pass to Wheeler off the corner boards CER there
to play it hermas checks him crder stays with it
finds him man the save by flurry put out in front
by capriso but broken up long shot from the point
wide the rebound played by capriso into the creas
was blocked you'll see 897 right there now watch
Miller come back and just tie up his stick there
was some room on the short side it's a thearon
long pass to laier Miller joins the play tro
moves in trailer is panan save by flurry got by
him but went wide that was deflected by Miller
front and center again in this period he gets this
shot but going to the front and that was Miller
watch Miller right there gets the redirection
and went through the legs of Mark Andre flurry
and just deflected the other way here comes again
paner with the shot you'll see the stick right
there breaks the blade of the stick and Miller was
that close to giving the Rangers a two- nothing
lead murmur back forward he's hit by
kie feno tried to clear stopped by kako
backhander save the rebound knocked away
from bino by flurry had numerous chances
in the last couple minutes including
that one there's a deflection and then
Bonino with that chance and flurry
does a good job with the stick but
good drove pitler can beion shot by Hartman saved
by De Ming r r sto by De Ming from his left to
his right quickly here comes the shot watch how
quickly he moves across and so he's there waiting
for the wraparound opportunity off the glass
one handed around to lingren from gustavson
kept in by Baldi nice play here Capri save made
by dingan he's got it he juggled it gloved it
under a minute to go in the Minnesota Power Play
dropped it back Johansson that's knocked away
break away Chek to the neet and he shot it wide
now here comes again the Rangers penalty killing
was really good here and then tro Rangers with
a one- nothing lead Minnesota had two shots on
on that power play Hartman with it now Faber the
defens man they score it was deflected in front I
Believe by duim yeah that's who it looked like Sam
again the the Rangers have spent an awful lot of
time deing goes behind the net can't make
a play Minnesota aggressively ends up with
the puck and then this shot you see all
those players in front looked like Duane
was there to get a piece of it bad was next
to Du and D just got it with a kicked in
Long Shot by hunt was blocked in front D and
Hunt misses wide chased down by Rossy Miller
on him Rossy to mosan save to Ming he's got
it that's what drew the crowd but Minnesota
is winning all the puck battles all the races
watch after he takes a watch to see if he chop
yeah chops him right across the so bad was
swinging at it with a stick and just missed
Rangers touch up in comes Guston Cuts in
Sav by flurry and he covers up oh what a
move rer down low for Linder trying to get
it to Wheeler CER in the corner wheeler in
front ker fir short side h Marco Rossi Rossy
Around the Net centers in front Rangers able
to break it up good play by Tek here's Panera
kek in the middle L frer left L Fier [Applause]
scores that's how you do it rers Le two to
one watch number seven Brock Faber in white
he's a defenseman you see him coming into
your play right there pinches in Rangers
make the defensive play now three onone
the other way beautiful pass easy tip in
and the Rangers use a defensive play that
goes to offense and in the net and that
quickly the Rangers come back and take
a 2-1 lead and then La Fier got knocked
down but a good shot Schneider inde deep
sets up K sa rebound is underneath flurry
four minutes gone by here in the SEC third
period and the Rangers with a two to one lead
driving to the front saved by deing kako
with a puck he's got [__] with him pun
checking him turns try to shot here's an open
and a great save FY Rob Bonino Bonino Bonino
fighting in front number 12 watch him find
the Puck look at that gaping net until that
stretch fantastic save by Mark Andre flurry
all that net Bono just got to slide it in and
he just open manand is [__] kie checked
by faab swings it around the boards the
wheeler fires it across Taco has it Miller laier
blocked in front rebound safe rebound St Blake
wheeler with his first goal as the New York
Ranger now they move it around and Wheeler
goes right to the front of the net rodine
stops the first one flurry stopped the second
and there was wheeler all alone and boy does
that feel good and that feels good he finally
gets one now these players zcell behind the net
now Baldi Baldi looks around battle going on
in front Hartman battling trouba shot toward
the net save rebound broid that was deflected I
think it hit trouba in the crease berino might
have saved a goal as zuk carella had an open
that on the other side he deflected it shot
by Baldi is wide Hartman back pass out of the
Zone he was pressured on the play by Capo kako
dipped in by Baldi 235 to go rangers leading
three to one chance in front s the Bing on
zuk carello ready to go rangers able to come out
and the s net is empty long shot score oh it's t
panarin [Applause] bullly and a multipoint game
for our T panan 22 points on the season he is
started this season pass will come across from
croch check behind him doesn't matter just stops
and drills it into the empty net Rangers Win It 4
to one welcome back to the NHL Lou Dain fin four